dreamworks animation vous replonge dans
l'ère préhistorique dans une toute
nouvelle série originale met flix tu vas
ça c'est fou du bocal préparent une
attaque surprise pas de chance pour
l'attack surpris les croods origines de
dreamworks même le commencement vous est
de loin le pire crook télé que je n'ai
jamais a eu un commencement
mais on est les seuls élèves que vous
ayez jamais eu et vous cette lépi la
première meilleure copine à dakar et tu
veux quand sa hache les coûts des
cheveux est content raconte tous nos
secrets noir tenant secret c'est que
j'ai une nouvelle meilleure copine le
premier animal de compagnie le premier
gourbeyre cette perte grâce à moi au
sort à six a un goût de verre où vient
de m
ou si c'est du buzz ou s'est rapidement
le début d'aventuré hystérique
on est des croquis rien au monde la main
pourquoi t'es toute nue c'est qu'en mer
vient de passer en mode surchauffe ce
qui veut dire que ça va être l'heure de
rentrer et les croûtes origines de
dreamworks seulement sur netflix